help me God so help me God Becca's mom  is at champs is now officially a lawyer  chanceless born in yesterday the  Thurgood Marshall School of Law in  Houston after passing the bar exam it is  quite an accomplishment especially for a  single mother of five children CBS News  first told you her story in April after  champs posted this picture with her  biggest supporter celebrating her  graduation milestone well you feel like  you're falling you feel like it's  impossible just keep going you don't  have to give up on your dream because of  something that you're currently going  through champ says she's hoping to  practice family and juvenile law and her  something about that and her family all  said we helped ya we're proud of you to  gradually a champ indeed